it'd be wrong not to mention the
multi-multi-billion dollar effort that
has gone into distracting us from all
this
[Music]
Mike berners-lee welcome to how the
light gets in thank you
your latest book is a sort of
extensively revised and updated edition
of your older book how bad are bananas
so
how does your new book move the
conversation forward how about a banana
is the carbon footprint of everything
that's my first book it came out in 2010
it's like a tour of carbon Footprints of
like it says everything you can think of
and to my amazement 10 years on people
were still buying it and I just felt
like
it needed a total update not just
because the numbers had changed but
because the whole context has changed
you know back then contact
UM climate was just a very serious thing
for us to be thinking about now we're in
a flat out climate emergency and the
whole kind of way that we
frame up everything to do with it needs
to be different and when I first wrote
that book I was very reluctant to tell
anybody what to do but of course as soon
as I started giving talks about it first
question was always well what should we
do so the new version has got a whole
section on what should we do not just
about climate but about the whole
situation that we're in I'm in a
slightly weird situation because I've
also updated there's no Planet B even a
couple of years after it came out which
is a much bigger take on the situation
that humans are in of which climate is
One symptom
but we've also got an ecological crisis
and or and all the rest of it and from a
technical and scientific point of view
the good news is we can deal with all of
that
but the real question is why aren't we
and what will it take for us to be able
to so that takes us into questions about
how our economics Works how our politics
Works How We Do Life
how honest we are
how much we respect each other at the
global level and all of that so I've got
these kind of two books
in parallel which are have a different
take on the same thing what are some
common misconceptions that people have
around the biggest sources of carbon
emissions
or are people now caught on to what what
those things are and or get it right but
more and more people understand the big
deals so people have always understood
that home energy is a deal and sure
enough it is and to varying extent you
know people have always understood that
cars have got because you are missions
because you can see them coming out of
the exhaust pipe people realize that
flying has got a big carbon footprint
but most people don't realize how big a
deal it is especially when you look at
high altitude factors and and so on food
more and more people are realizing that
food is a big deal
and one of the good developments has
been that you know whereas 10 years ago
people were talking about food miles the
whole time which are usually unless
something's been on an airplane
peripheral now the debate is much more
centrally focused on the amount of meat
and dairy in our diet and how we do that
meat and dairy and that's good that's
what it should be and also the kind of
movement for Less
um less stuff you know thinking about
what we buy and where it comes from and
making things last and all that kind of
stuff and it's great to be at this
festival and see you know a whole stand
for secondhand shoes and you know all
sorts of kind of circular economy type
things so that agenda's moved on a bit
so moving on to a little bit on there's
no plan at B and this kind of question
of like
why are we not doing quite enough
let me ask you first where do you stand
on this question of where the locus of
responsibility for climate change for
the Environmental
crisis lies
does it lie with individuals and our
individual behaviors you know whether we
recycle whether we switch to vegetarian
diets or are we never really going to be
able to solve this if we're just
thinking about the individual and not
the kind of structural problems of the
economy and so on well we need to think
about all these things where does the
responsibility like it's a great
question it lies everywhere it lies all
of us have a responsibility to do what
we can to exert our influence in
whatever ways we think we can to bring
about this help create the conditions
under which human humans can bring about
the big systemic change that we need to
see so you know cutting our carbon
Footprints is one corner of that and yes
we should try and be responsible and so
on and by doing so we send out messages
to the people around us and we also
start sort of learning from our personal
experience of the micro
about what some of the change in the
macro might look like so that personal
stuff does matter
you know in terms of our own direct
impact but the more deeply you think
your way into this it becomes more you
know much more to do with how we do
Society How We Do economics how we do
politics uh how we treat each other the
kind of respect with which we the people
of the world do or don't treat each
other and the extent to which we value
truth
so I think you know there's no Planet
B's got a chapter or two about about
truth and respect in it uh and if I was
ever going to write another book I think
it would all be about
how can we do a better job of making
sure that the people in powerful
positions are people who are honest and
people who care about all the people of
the world because without that we can't
get anywhere and I you know I find
myself in lots of debates about
all sorts of my new Thai questions like
how should we do meat and dairy or
should we have a new coal mine in the
off the west coast of Cumbria and stuff
like that and the art the logic of those
arguments is so clear-cut we should have
them once and then it should be done and
we end up with spending months or years
just going around around and the reason
for that is because there are so many
people in the system who've got the
wrong motives and we shouldn't have them
there you know and are being and are
being careless with the truth and you
know the people of the world
you know including the people of the UK
uh if we don't want to head for a very
nasty place we need to get much much
hotter at just stopping all of that from
happening and getting the right people
into positions of of power and
responsibility
Let's uh focus a little bit of this
relationship between the kind of
individual and the collective or the
state level so what do you think
explains the fact that people are
reluctant to change their behaviors when
it comes to driving a petrol car or
eating meat or flying when they know
that those behaviors can be detrimental
onto the environment and yet a lot of us
keep doing those things it's not it's no
longer a question of information you
know change is required and very often
we get resistant to change especially if
we can't imagine what's going to be good
about that change when we don't spend
enough time really working up the vision
for how a more sustainable future can
actually also be a better one to live in
for everybody the quality of life can go
up the quality of our communities can go
up you know Our Lives can feel more
meaningful we'll go around happier
because we'll know deep down that we're
not trashing the place I mean all kinds
of things will just get better but we
don't spend enough time imagining that
that that's the first thing it'd be
wrong not to mention the
multi-multi-billion dollar effort that
has gone into distracting us from all
this pulling the wool over our eyes
misinformation but not just uh you know
there has been a lot of very cynical
deliberate misinformation but there's
also the you know the kind of messages
that we receive all the time to just
carry on as normal if you know any time
you turn on the Telly anytime you you
know most of the information we streams
that we get and 99 of the advertising is
just nudging us to carry on as normal
and forget about all that stuff that's
difficult to look at and I think the
third thing is that people feel very
often a lack of agency
so when you wake up to the climate
emergency uh
you know if when the minute you start to
think about it properly you realize that
it's a big Global systemic problem
requiring a big Global systemic response
and each one of us is just one eight
billionth of the whole thing and it's
easy to feel really powerless and then
when you think about it you think well
you know I could cut my carbon footprint
but you start understanding about things
like rebound effects and you realize
that actually the direct saving that you
think you're making is going to the
Slack's going to get taken up somewhere
else that's the way the Dynamics of it
all work
until we can get the conditions right
for a big systemic change and that
leaves a lot of people feeling helpless
but I think the empowering way to ask
the question what can I do is how can I
help to create the conditions under
which the global systemic change can
become possible and that that actually
opens up a much wider agenda it's like
what can be my influence on politics
what can my be my influence on the
workplace every time I spend money I'm
sending out a message about the kind of
future I want to support or not support
I mean it's just it's just a massively
more empowering question to ask and
every time you have a conversation
you're pushing one way or another let me
focus a bit on the first thing you
mentioned there which is that we can't
quite imagine
what future this might
lead to and the reason for that is I
think that most of the time we are told
what the future will look like if we
just continue and that kind of
apocalyptic version of the future
doesn't seem to be motivating enough so
are we just focusing on the wrong side
instead of focusing on like the positive
effects of action as it were like
imagining a kind of positive future yeah
we should be focusing on both of those
things and and we should be focusing on
the difference between if if we carry on
as we are and if we don't carry on as we
are so you know I think you know I I'm a
great believer in just saying it like it
is accurately not trying to dress it up
for the purposes of you know
motivating people one way or another I
think we should stick with the facts
right so the facts are if we carry on as
we are we don't know with any certainty
that blow by blow how things will go but
what we do know with really quite a lot
of certainty is that we're in for a very
very nasty time and it won't just be
those poor people living in countries
thousands of miles away who always seem
to end up having a hard time you know
the the whole of global Society is going
to be in for an awful lot of trouble
nobody quite knows the exact mechanism
by which that'll happen but it's that's
clear-cut on the other hand if we take
really strong action really really
quickly now which means radically
different from anything that we've
really begun to see so far
it looks likely but not definite that we
can broadly speaking get away with this
by which I mean
the number of people who die from
ecological problems that we've been
inflicting will remain in the millions
rather than the billions right and for
most people the quality of life on Earth
could arguably be better than ever right
but it really is
uh it's a it's a huge change and the
stuff that you hear about you know in
the sort of normal
political rhetoric about Net Zero by
2050 you know even that is just a sticky
plaster on climate change as one one
specific thing
actually you know we're facing a a rack
of ecological
uh problems of which climate is just one
of them to focus on what you talked
about
um in your third point the kind of
powerlessness and the kind of lack of
agency of the individual you did say
that you think structural change at the
global level needs to happen so not only
should we be trying to influence our own
politicians that we have some form of
control over through you know Democratic
means but somehow the rest of the world
as well like what is the what is the
medium through which we can enact that
change well a lot of it is through our
politicians for most of us and it's
about insisting on you know you know the
to take the Ukraine for example which is
really interesting because it you know
it flushes out just how far we are at
the moment from the level of
international cooperation and trust that
we're going to absolutely need
throughout the eight or nine billion or
however many you know we're going to
absolutely need that we we need it so
urgently and Ukraine
throws into sharp relief how far away we
are from that and you know the ways in
which we respond in the UK are
influential I know we send out
influential messages about you know in
all sorts of ways you know it's partly
about standing up to Russia okay sure
but also uh the for example the way in
which we either do or don't take
ukrainians
into this country and you know do what
we can for them you know that sends out
a message about how much we care about
people who live elsewhere from us I
think the pandemic was another example
you know what we missed was an
opportunity to demonstrate to the World
by spreading vaccine early out to
developing countries that we respect all
the people of the world and by kind of
you know playing our cars close to our
chest and grabbing as much vaccine as we
could you know first and foremost you
know we sent out a message that we're
still not in that mindset that's a real
that's such a shame but you know all of
this stuff we can influence by pushing
our politicians not just by how we vote
but by letting them know in advance of
the elections the kinds of things that
matter and you know
um and by screaming more loudly when we
encounter politicians who are being
careless with the truth or who are
putting up with other politicians being
careless with the truth well let's focus
on the pandemic
um you know climate change is in some
ways for a lot of people something that
happens in the future the covert was
something that happened to them in the
present and as you say we did see that
when it comes to crisis people first and
foremost take care of the nation-state
and then maybe some neighboring
countries and then maybe some other
countries that we have some kind of
cultural ties with and they're kind of
Peters out is it realistic to think that
we are capable at a state level to
express this kind of radical altruism
towards everyone else in the world yeah
when we wake up yeah I mean if it you
know to look at good things that come
came out of the pandemic I mean it
showed us that we can change it shows
actually changes pretty you know much
more changed than we had thought it's
actually pretty easy you know the
pandemic was um an unpleasant experience
for most people but the actual change
part of it wasn't wasn't particularly
difficult if we were to implement that
level of change in a way that was
designed to look after people and Planet
at the same time so that it wasn't a bad
experience I mean it would just you know
it would be a lot a lot easier that you
know the difficulty is you know we woke
up to the pandemic because people could
imagine what it would be like to catch
covid or to have a loved one catch
covered and die you know and it so we
had a strong emotional reaction to it as
humans we're much
uh we're much less good at having a
powerful emotional reaction when we
think about something that uh might not
be happening within the next few weeks
and
it's easy to imagine might not affect us
it might only affect other people and by
the way I think that shows a real
paucity of imagination anybody who kind
of thinks about climate change is
something that's not really really going
to hit people in the UK I think they
just haven't properly worked through how
fragile Global Society is and I think
you know what if there's something
healthy about the pandemic it reminded
people of my age for example
that uh civilized you know the sort of
stability of civilization that I have
always known you know my neck of the
woods Society has been a very very
stable thing you can you know you could
just you could just ignore those
environmental Nutters and it's fine you
know prove decade out to decade it's
fine and the pandemic showed us you know
it's we can't take that kind of thing
for granted actually we should we should
fight for it but let me challenge you a
little bit on the claim that well it was
easy to change behaviors during the
pandemic and so we can do it again I
mean in some ways change happened
because like literally the state banned
certain activities so we stopped flying
around the world because well we
couldn't it was illegal to do so is that
is that going to be what's required for
dealing with the climate crisis is it
going to require kind of mass
legislation that bans social activities
well what happened in the first lockdown
at least was that you know the
government took in the end strong action
and the people were broadly speaking
behind them so they could get away with
it and they could make things against
the law and there wasn't going to be
writing on the streets and anyone who
stepped out of line was more often than
not put back in line not by the
government but by the people around them
who you know thought they should be
doing the right thing and the government
had some credibility when it you know
when it when it
um when it pushed for that change and I
think if we can get to the same
situation on our response to the climate
and ecological crisis then you know our
governments aren't our leaders in the
way that we might you know we might
possibly
want them to be or you know they in a
way they follow they follow us so when
for example uh Extinction rebellion and
the and the school kids taking to the
streets you know pre-pandemic this you
know when that happened it was pretty
clear-cut that they opened up the
political space for politicians in the
UK not to go all the way on everything
they should do on climate change but to
take one or two really important good
steps in the right direction and I think
it illustrates the point that there's a
kind of you know there's if you like
there's about three key groups in this
there's the politicians there's the
business community and there's the
public and
um each one of those influences the
others and gives space to the others and
makes it easier for the others to go and
take the next step so that's those three
groups need to move
together ideally it was about another
dis uniformity with the pandemic which
was we were always told this is a
temporary situation these measures are
not forever these will last for a few
months maybe a year but they ended up
lasting a bit longer than that but they
weren't forever
so what do you think people would be as
receptive
if we told them well you're never
getting on a plane again ever
we don't need to say that uh
you know the pandemic was
uh you know for most people the you know
the changes in behavior that we had to
do were fundamentally unpleasant the
changes in behavior that we need to do
in order to have a lot more sustainably
are fundamentally unbalanced not
unpleasant they don't need to be you
know we can a lot of us can get away
with uh can get away from aspects of our
jobs that we actually hate aspects of
society that we hate spending time in
traffic jams you know uh you know all
kinds of there's all kinds of stuff you
know a proper built environment will be
one that's actually not only a lot more
energy efficient but more pleasant to
live in you know actually what's not to
life what's not to like you know the the
quality of our community engagement will
go up uh or you know all sorts of things
will be improvements in a way that we
couldn't have with the pandemic so
whilst there's a lot of change it's not
fundamentally a bitter pill you could if
you look at what we had to do for the
pandemic we had to swallow a bit of pill
so we didn't die
if we're smart about this we're going to
swallow an unusual pill but actually you
know once we've had it we'll figure oh
guys you know this is good so given that
we haven't seen the radical change that
we need so far what do you think needs
to change how do you see the shift
happening both at individual level that
most people take up habits like eating
less meat traveling less by plane but
also at the collective level or the
level of Estates what are we expecting
to happen that's actually going to shift
gears that hasn't happened so far
I think it'll happen from everywhere at
once I think it's like a systemic change
that will have you know it's not that
one thing will precipitate the changes
in other things I think the conditions
will become right and then everything
will fall into place probably you know
simultaneously and I think you know at
the moment there are little bits of
dietary change and there are a few
people around who are flying less and so
on but if you look at the amount of meat
that's being consumed at the national
level it's not really changing much
anything right so we're not at that
point yet and the question is are we
starting to see you know for us with a
system change you can push and push and
push you feel like you're getting
absolutely nowhere and then you see a
couple of cracks in the old system and
it can be a very short space of time
indeed before the whole thing flips over
so the question is how close are we to
that huge Tipping Point when if you look
at the kind of you know if you look at
the sort of material measures of how
we're doing you know it's spectacular
really pathetic if you were if you were
on Mars looking at data on planet Earth
to see how we're getting on with climate
change you know you look at our
emissions curve going up and up and
that's still rising and as in the amount
of emissions every year is still by and
large bigger than the year before you'd
you'd notice that humans have had a
pandemic if you look to that curve you'd
notice that the USSR got dissolved you'd
notice that we had a client a an
economic crunch in 2008 right but you
wouldn't see from that curve that humans
have woken up to climate change like not
at all so you know materially we're
absolutely miles away
but how are we seeing the first cracks
that tell us we might only be a very
short distance
in a way I think the pandemic put us
back
uh in some respects because I think with
the traction that some of the protesters
were getting and the sort of General
momentum behind things I think
pre-covered there was quite a clear
pathway in a in a way to getting the
change we needed to see in the and the
pandemic confused all of that and I
think Ukraine is confusing all of that
um as well which is uh dangerous
so you see the change not happening
gradually but basically there being a
kind of moment of Reckoning and then
suddenly
what happens gradually is that is that
the systemic conditions become right for
the change and you start noticing that
in sort of you know the way that all
sorts of things the way the BBC talks
about it the kind of things that
politicians feel they can say you know
out loud I notice it I run a company
that works with businesses the kind of
conversations we're having those with
those businesses used to be sort of
little conversations about how can we
cast our carbon footprint now they're
much more conversations about we get it
there's a there's an emergency going on
we get it that this affects everything
about how every business when every
business thinks says and does you know
and businesses are coming to us asking
for a much more holistic assessment
of everything they could and should be
doing to exert that influence for
systemic change that's a that's a
changing conversation right now it's
only in a few leading businesses and all
the rest of it but you know
these things can take off suddenly
you've said climate change isn't a
technological problem it's a problem of
values
so do you really think that values are
going to change and lead to this kind of
shift or is it going to be more
a kind of reaction to self-preservation
and a realization that
we are under threat our way of life is
under threat the planet is under threat
and so it won't really be values that
guide our change of behavior but really
a very selfish reaction to what's going
on well you can sort of construe
everything is as selfish if you if you
really put your mind to it you can be
cynical about anything but I mean I
think it's clear-cut just you know just
from a practical point of view we are
eight billion of us on this fragile
Planet together and we will either deal
with the situation together or not at
all it just it can't be done without a
level of global cooperation I was in
Ukraine I was in Kiev at a conference
about eight months ago zielinski gave
the opening talk and everybody was all
the wise people were saying oh he's a
nice man but a bit of a weak leader and
uh but you know with that the conference
was all about uh climate and security
and China and Russia
an artificial intelligence those are the
kind of big themes that came out was
like a big strategy conference and half
the parliament was there and so on and
the the big underlying question that I I
think was going through the conference
was can humans
fundamentally come to a point where they
collaborate at a global level
in a way we've never seen before can we
radically uh you know can we make that
radical Evolution right now
and there were two schools of thought in
the room there were the near liberals I
was a one-hearted professor in
particular you know seem to be really
enjoying himself telling everybody that
you can't trust anybody in this world
it's a it's it's a dog eat dog world
uh and there was me you know making a
different case and one or two others
Rook to bregman was there the author of
humankind you know and but you know my
take on it is that if you look at the
historical evidence and the social
evidence and the neurological evidence
you know the the real evidence tells us
that humans are capable of uh through
deliberate effort
cultivating a set of values
the the values that we need to see us
through Living Well in the anthropocene
so it's doable we are you know we are
capable of that level of cooperation
what we haven't yet managed to do is
scale it up to the global level because
we haven't yet got good we we've we've
we've globalized we've reached a point
at which everything we do in our lives
has Global implications
but what we haven't yet managed to do is
get to the point where we have emotional
reactions
about those implications that a
commensurate with you know with the kind
of impacts that we have so that's
something we need to learn you know
quickly
Mike burners Lee thank you very much
pleasure
for more debates talks and interviews so
subscribe today to The Institute of Arts
and ideas her IAI TV
[Music]